Last time we looked at the,
at the Canto of Canto 15,
or in fair nor the Canto of Brunette told
the teacher of Dante's teacher and the
teacher or the Florentines. And we, um,
and we pointed out the,
the,
the rhetoric of the cancer after
all Burrito is a master restoration.
Uh,
so it was quite appropriate.
The dantes account of his meeting with
his teacher will be carried out through a
careful, very careful, uh,
highlighting of the
ambiguities of language.
The way language is used very carefully
to mean one thing for one order
experience grenade,
toes for instance,
anthropocentric political
understanding of the world.
And then, uh, Dante, his own
understanding of the world,
which we could call theological,
but it really means, uh,
the point of view of
someone who is cresting,
who is moving and who will
move beyond a Brunette.
And how a language oscillates the same
words seem to acquire different meanings
in those different contexts.
And in many ways that language,
it would become the
language that rhetoric,
which should be the instrumental
persuasion and agreement becomes in and of
itself the cause of two of
misunderstandings between them.
Between master and uh, and disciple. Uh,
but, uh, the, the candle
Burrito for all of its, uh,
the intensity and poignancy over personal,
uh,
confrontation of, of a, of a
disciple who meets his teacher.
And the many ways shows even there there's
a sort of great deal of ambivalence,
a great deal of acknowledgement
or recognition of the
importance of Brunette was
teaching on him. But at the same time, uh,
assault of distance taking
leave, taking from a, uh,
that teaching that too though
for its private took quality.
The quality of the great humanistic
values of, uh, are acknowledging,
uh,
the teaching that shows the way
to how main makes himself eternal.
That is says anthropocentric.
It can be that kind of, uh,
of, of, of, uh, aphorism in a way,
which is, which is the way Dante,
uh,
seals the personality of Rachel.
And yet it always had or
actually has as always this,
this,
this exploding personal encounters
doing Dante a political focus.
It was something a little bit
larger than their own private story.
It is the encounter between them was
placed within the crisis of Florence,
uh, the CTO, Florence, the divisions
between wells and get bylines.
And then there's also the
announcements, uh, to Brunette to,
to Dante Bible rate to that he is
going to go into his going to end up,
uh, in, in, in exile that the comfort, uh,
the human bonds, the comfort of
the city and family and whatnot,
even that will be denied to
him, uh, for Burrito. Of course,
there is also strategy of, uh, uh,
thinking that Dante's own experience is,
it's really the mirror image of his own.
Because as you remember,
and I said this at the beginning
of my remarks last time,
Brunetto all's experiences,
Eh,
exile as he was in, Ron
says, Val, uh, the, the,
the classical place of the most
traumatic experience in medieval history.
The,
the,
the place where the Paladin roll
on a Orlando in Italia Roma,
uh, and, and the Carolingian drama,
the Charlemagne soldiers are the
fitted and Brunetto. That's where he,
he, that's how he views
his own defeat in the, uh,
in the city of Florence.
So there was always a public focus and
the public focus was not just a context
for their relationship, but they, it,
it was really a way of shedding light on
the very nature of their own divisions.
Uh, it is as if, uh,
the oscillations of language that they
experience in the exchange between them
are really consequences. Also
have larger divisions, uh,
larger suspicions that this,
uh,
characters living in Florence
entertain told each other.
I mentioned that because I'm
going to move today to Canton 19.
We've taken quite a jump.
We went through 16,
we saw the flight on the back of
Jerry and some, some, some, uh,
adumbration got fried on the
back of [inaudible], uh, uh,
can to 17.
If you were to read it on your own.
It's an extraordinary cantor.
It's the only time that
virtual leaves Dante alone.
And Donna has to, uh,
uh, mean there the, the,
the usual hours. And he
had, and it is as if, uh,
he had to be left without any guidance.
It is if he hit to discover bite himself
and by his own powers or what those
temptations are and what the implications
of usually it would be for him. And,
and there may be a biographical
biographical resonance
there in the sense that,
uh,
a neuron with a poet as edging toward the,
the,
the condition of the user are engaged
in the illusory recreation's illusory
productions, but also at
biographical, a reference to,
to Dante's own father who
was engaged in that sort of,
um, of activity. And then
we go through a Kantar 19,
which is really the cancer
I want to talk about now.
And that's the point of my remarks
about medical situations of what I said
about, about Brunetto.
I'll takes a public voice,
not only takes it so you have a,
uh,
an experience of the
shifts in his own voice.
So you do know the kind of romance
atmosphere in the encounter with,
uh, uh, with, with Francesca,
uh, you do have the kind of,
uh,
the seminar like tones that he uses in
the encounter in limbo with the poets of
antiquity, where he, they
go on talking about art.
And the secrets of the craft,
et Cetera. Now Dante takes what?
A headset.
I do not hesitate to call a
prophetic voice if pub he plays.
Now he sees himself as a public
role. They shift all the, the,
the change that departure from,
uh,
the political rhetorical
tone, uh, used and they,
and they encounter with, uh, with
Kurento could not be more vocal north,
be sharper, more radical. This
is, uh, uh, this is, uh, uh,
an argument now that engages him as a
public figure as it were indeed as a
profit. So what does it mean to be
a prophet for Dante? What kind of,
how can one take on this sort of, uh, of,
of voice?
How does one go on?
How does it profit?
A talk like a one thing that you make,
you want to keep in mind is I go
on to understand this candle is a,
if clearly the pattern for all of this,
the model to be the
prophetic voice in the Bible,
the biblical prophets,
and do not make a mistake of thinking
for a moment that profits are those who
are foretell the future. That's
not really their role. In fact,
Dante goes out of the way,
and I'm not going to talk about that,
but really they haven't
got time and can to 20, uh,
highlighting the differences were
between prophets and diviners,
the diviners or those who
for tail predict the future.
So if the profits do not foretell
the future, what do they do?
They are literally readers of the present.
This is the point for Dante.
The Biblical prophets are those who read
the present history in its unfolding
from the perspective of what they perceive
to have been God's promise to Israel
and to them.
So the profits are in a way and that not,
I don't say this in any way to,
to uh,
to degrade them, but I,
on the, on the contrary,
to highlight the importance
of the intervention into
the presence that you could
call them as commentators. Those who
are in the true sense of the word,
those who remember, that's what a
commentator is a commentator is,
it's an exercise of memory,
a way of bringing ancient
memories to bear on the present.
That's the way Dante understands
the prophetic prophetic voice.
And Nether little detail
before we go on with the Canto.
You do not know.
Some of you may know that that
actually is a writer of many epistles.
He was a letter writer.
We do not know the letters he
wrote on behalf of his patrons,
but we do know the letters
that he wrote in his own name.
And he would be a writing letters
that the array of which is, uh,
can be sometimes moving. Uh, for
instance, when he writes to a friend, uh,
he would like to attend the funeral
of his friend's wife and cannot,
he said practically begging because he
doesn't have the adequate clothes to go
to the funeral,
introduce him.
So he's clearly begging for
some kind of assistance.
But he writes also letters that
probably never reached the destination.
He wrote letters, for instance, to
the Italian cardinals who were, uh,
in conclave. You, you understand what I'm
saying? What I mean when I say conclave,
the conclave,
it means that they are shut on the key
and kept in some place where they can
make decisions about electing from within
themselves or from the outside a pope.
And they could not agree about whom
to choose. So he writes a letter,
a letter to the Italian cardinals,
and he begins the letter are addressing
them as in perhaps all of you will
wonder who is this man who
gives him the authority to say,
to speak to us and address dressers and
spur us on to action that's in here.
Remember,
this is Dante speaking and attributing
this thoughts to the cardinals.
They are the possible objection to the
intervention of a layman's voice within
sacred things fast.
He remember the lesson
of the Biblical prophet,
which he doesn't mention.
Uh, the name is mentioned,
who on seeing the arc of the,
of the alliance being carried into,
into the city of Jerusalem
and seeing the are tottering.
He stretches his hand,
trying to protect it to, to,
to make sure that it won't collapse and
break into pieces and God intervenes
and, and through lightening and
four minutes and man kills him.
So Dante's aware of the danger
of taking on. That's the point.
He goes home,
say spring them.
So I'm not really touching
the ark and Brady spring,
the oxen who are not going anywhere.
Let's see the absence of the letter,
but this does not concern us here.
But the point of concerns as here is that
in the background to this canto where
he takes on the prophetic voice,
he's aware of the possible profit
nation that he's engaged in,
in addressing as he does
the so called symbolists,
it's time to get into the Canto of the
so called symbolists who are the similes,
uh, in fact that we just saw, I
was just reading this little story,
the sisters of, of joys that I
have been reading that before.
But I know that that is really a story of,
I don't know how many of
you are English, uh, uh,
students and students of
English literature, but he
writes these stories about,
so two 20, early 20th century
version of, uh, of Simonia.
And if someone of you might want
to write a paper, uh, connecting,
uh,
the sisters,
this beautiful gem of a story by
[inaudible] and Canton 19, you can,
and you see the differences that they are,
uh, that the, between the two of them,
the similar lists are of
the followers. It's, it's a,
it's a word. Uh, like we said,
they're machiavellians. For instance,
our followers of Machiavelli's those who
think like Machiavelli, the Simone is,
are the followers of Simon who was
called a mongoose or a sorcerer or a
magician.
Simon Simon.
And actually we call this phenomenon
when you have a name that gives,
sort of creates a trend
or a way of thinking,
it's called an EP on him.
I thought that you might from
the Greek [inaudible] him,
this is an Simoni Simoni of
the photos is uh, Simon, uh,
the magician. So it's Dante
is beginning the story, um,
with a reference to a founding event
in the constitution of the church,
goes back to the acts of the apostles
were there is this story that of,
of a sourcer men engaged
in witchcraft in illusions.
Simon who wants to buy the gift of
prophecy and the power of making miracles
from Peter,
and therefore then he challenges him to,
or let's see who can fly,
et Cetera,
and then they go up on a tower
and tied to fry Simon. Of course,
we'll go down and we'll die.
What Dante's doing?
He's now encountering the
popes of his own time.
Nicholas the fifth bone, if
it's the eighth, one of the
great minds, great jurist,
by the way. Uh, in fact, there are those
storylines who really think that Dante is,
is a dead mouse in him. That you know,
there's some something personal that we,
we can't quite see bone if it's the
eighth and Clement, the sixth, the fifth,
I'm sorry,
the three popes and whom Dante lived,
who are engaged in say money.
What is symphony?
It's a sacrilege.
Symphony is the act exactly like Simon
in the acts of the apostles who wanted to
buy the gift of prophecy.
It is a sin whereby one can go on in
making commerce of sacred things and
thereby engaging in blast.
For me. The question then is,
what does Dante thing this hate crime is?
It's a constant theme in his,
uh,
in his reflections is a constant
theme of his thoughts. Uh,
what is the sacred, how
do we determine it? How,
what does it mean to violate this sacred?
Simon violates the sacred
that pope now who are, uh,
of his own generation are engaged in
the same kind of blasphemy and the same
kind of profit nation and in effect,
let me just give you a little detail
that you might appreciate this ambiguity.
The other neighbor of Peta, you know,
Saint Peter, the guy with the two keys,
we saw an illusion to him. We can to
13. The other name of Peter is Simon,
so he's, in fact, he's known. It's Simon
Peter. It is as if by having this tool,
the, the, the, the sourcer,
the magician called Simon and
the pope called Simon Peter,
and they should be a,
or who successors.
That's pope's should be the first pope
and the other. He's Dantes actually,
uh, uh, giving us a sense
of what we call for,
give them the, the rhetorical
term, immature Nimic proximity,
a contiguity in near illness between them.
The nearest between the
prophetic mode and a,
the perforation of the prophetic mode.
How,
how precarious is the boundary
line that divides the two?
How precarious the divide
line that separates the, the,
the sacred from the proffer
nation of the sacred.
So this is really what Dante's,
we'll see how he dramatizes all of us.
First of all. And the question that I
raised with you is how do profits tall?
And one thing that you will
see here is the apostrophe.
This is a candle written in terms
of a positive is look at this. Um,
and we read the Canto. So I'm reading
the Canto. This is for the transcriber.
Uh, um, can talk 19.
Ah, Simon Margot's.
There is the apostrophe.
Think about why their posture,
what is an apostrophe?
And you,
his Richard followers who rapacious
prostitute for gold and silver,
the things of God, we should be
brides of righteousness. Yeah,
that's the definition of Samaria. Uh,
viewed us and adultery, a corruption,
therefore of the chastity, of, of, uh,
of the marriage between God and the soul.
Now must the trumpet sound for you,
for your place in is in the third pouch.
We were now at the next tomb and
that climb to that part of the ridge,
which hangs right over the
middle of the ditch. Oh,
and other parts and other invocational
would call it, but it's, it's,
I'm not so sure that we can quiet that.
I couldn't quite decide the
difference in between an invocation,
which is obviously a
prayerful and an apostrophe,
a calling on and address a,
that's what the apostrophes,
how great is the art that shows in
heaven on earth and in the evil world.
And how Justin it has that power.
The Spence I saw along the
sides and on the bottom,
they live in stone full of holes.
All of one size in niche was rounds.
They seem to me of a,
with no more or less than those that
were made in my beautiful Saint John the
Baptist story of Saint John in Florence.
And these are this, uh, the, the,
the wells were baptisms take place
that usually octagonal in shape.
The eighth day, you know, the, the, the,
the idea that the rest of the direction
is on the eighth day. Uh, it's, it's, uh,
it's, it's the idea of history
based on the seven days of creation,
the eighth day of the resurrection,
they were made in my beautiful
Saint John as funds for baptism,
one of which not many years
ago I broke for wonder,
was drowning in it.
And to this,
I set my seal to clear the
mind of everyone with Dante's
doing is acknowledging
what could,
what could have been seen as
an act of profound nation.
He broke one,
which is really as a figurative because
they're are huge and I can't believe
that he could have the unit 10
people to break these things apart.
Uh,
so it's a figurative idea that he
stretched his head into holy things and
violated the holy things.
But he did it.
And that's the excuse is giving a,
he did it in order to save someone's life.
So there is nothing gratuitous.
That's the point in his own
intervention as it is called.
It's called an intervention in Zachary's
stretching the profane hands into holy
things and two sacred things
where he's, what he is really, uh,
removing himself from is the charge
that is act may appear purely gratuitous
prayer or to the tutors.
And if it's not gratuitous,
what is it driven by?
Where does it come from if it's not,
one can say, well, it's a gratuitous
act, which means you can dismiss it,
but this is not the two, two. So what
is the reason behind it then he, he,
if he serious enough,
it should provide us this region from
the mouth of which projected of each
projected the feet of a center and the
legs as far as the calf and the rest of
us inside.
He's representing the popes were here
upside down. That's the way,
that's the way Simon fail.
And they'll give a little
story about that too.
It was also the position that according
to legend Saint Peter wanted for
himself.
He asked that he be buried upside down
because he wanted to show what the cue,
the erection of for the soldiers are sent.
And purification would be the idea that
wedding, I remember in an inverted world,
a world which is upside down, and
therefore to be with a head down you, you,
you are really a right side up.
You are going toward the,
toward your proper destination so that
it is playing with this iconographic
Motif of Peter who asks to be
crucified with head upside down.
And the story of Simon who very
much like him now is as a, as a, as,
as, as a punishment is
with the head upside down.
How were they punished in an avert pat
or day of the Pentecost and the flames of
fire? You know, the
story of the Pentecost.
That's the story of the Pentecost is the
story of the gift of language that come
down as a rain of fire on them.
Now they have flames on their feet.
This is what,
this is the soul to have a horrible,
uh,
turning around of, uh, of
prophecy. End of the, of the,
of the gift of languages,
meaning that we all speak
everybody else's language,
which clearly means I'm sure that
that was polyglots among view,
but it clearly means that we all speak
one language language of charity and
therefore we can all understand
each other that way. So, uh,
that's uh,
that they would have snapped with his uh,
and ropes is flames on oily thing,
on oily things,
the old unction. Uh, so it's
a further allusion to the,
this equation that is taking place
here moves only over the outer surface.
So it did there from the heels to the toe.
Who is that one done tasks,
wants to know who it is that he's his
master that rides in his torment more than
any of his fellows.
I said,
and this licked by a red flame and he
answered me if that will have me carry the
down there by that more sloping bank.
Does Sheryl know from himself
of him and of his misdeeds
and I all is.
Well for me,
that is a pressure that with my load and
knows the depart node from the wheel,
the nose to what I do not speak.
Then we came on to the fourth dike,
turned and descended on our left
down to the pitted and narrow bottom.
And the good master did not set me down
from his home to he brought me to a
whole of him, the solar mentored
with his shanks, whoever,
whoever that wallet I began unhappy
sold that are held upside down,
planted like a post if
that were able to speak.
And now the series of inversions
is introduced here. I,
Dante says stood there like the fryer.
He is the layman to changing of roles
and the pope who is going to be unveiled
his own reveal his own identity
in a moment. He is there, uh,
like an assassin because an
assassin that perfidious assassin,
I mean the one who broke faith, that's
what the word, uh, perfectly, uh,
means that Shrives the
treasures intolerance,
the paddle fee though as an assassin who
have to being fixed calls him back so
that he delays is that,
and he cried.
This is the one of the pope's
Nicholas who misunderstands,
but the misunderstanding
is highly suggestive.
He's telling Dante and us
that the reigning pope or
Dante's writing Bonafides,
the eighth, one of the RCD
family, one of the great families,
Roman families has already arrived.
And he says standard style.
They're already standard stuff.
They're already Bonhoeffer's by
several years the writing lied to me.
And also soon sated with this gains,
which thou did not fear
to take that by guy,
the lady beautiful and
then do her outrage. So,
uh, this is uh, uh, the comic con,
the accusation that Dan
picking launch, Eh, the,
the figures of power,
the prophet who takes home a
power and unveils it's abusers.
I became like those that
stand as if marked, uh,
not comprehending the reply made to
them and knew not what to answer.
And Virgil said, tell him quickly, I'm
not here, I'm not here, that are thinkers.
And I answered as if as I was bitten
and that the spirit twisted his feet
together, then sign in with
lamenting voice. He said to me,
what does the want with me then?
If to know who I am, concerns the,
so much that has come
down the bank for it.
Know that I was invested with a
great mantle and so on. And Dante,
we'll go on into, uh,
uh, a general attack,
uh, which is really the, the prophetic
moment. Let me just, uh, I do not know.
I'm reading from lines 90 and
following. I do not know if, uh,
on that I was over bold when all my
answer to him was in the strain. Pray.
Tell me now,
how much treasure did our Lord require
of Saint Peter Before he gave keys into
his charge?
Surely he has nothing but follow me.
Nor did Peter on the other take gold
or silver from attires and so on.
So this is Dante. Now, uh,
the Prophet Dante, the,
the, the man who speaks because, and he,
he feels that he ought to speak.
And that's the distance taking from the
gratuitousness of the accusation because
all figures of authority lack in the
presence of this eclipse of authority.
He thinks that it is incumbent upon him
to go on taking that authority used to
have patient of over voice is a patient
of authority in order to make up for
what he thinks is missing.
And the problem, uh,
this whole question about the,
the,
the confusion of orders,
the confusion between the secular and
the sacred and profane and the sacred is
brought back to one great event,
which was known in the Middle
Ages as the second sin of Adam.
It was so great. They understand
what the first sin of Adam was.
The transgression or the
transgression of the,
the command given to him not
to eat of the tree of the,
the, the, the forbidden tree are
the forbidden fruit of the tree. Uh,
the vent,
Dante goes back to his event of the so
called donation of Constantine about
which I want to say a few things and
then we move on to the next cancers.
And so it's the donation of Constantine.
It is a refers to the fourth century
when the Emperor Constantine,
whose name I think I
have mentioned, uh, uh,
gave extended,
gave the land to the
pope x in other words,
made the po the ruler of a secular,
um,
domain to Dante.
This was a confusion of registers,
a confusion of responsibilities that
the pope should be only engaged in
spiritual pursuits and spiritual matters.
He becomes instead involved
in secular matters.
So that scene of ceremony is
really the problem between, uh,
the has to do with the donation.
Of course in an issue. By the way,
and I will tell you why this
is important in a second.
The issue is we'll be really clarified
around the 15th century when two figures,
two people, two figures,
one is Cruzan knows,
some of you may know him or Nicholas
of cruiser went on repeating the moral
arguments against the donation of
Constantine as much as Dante does here.
But the one who really proved the
falseness of the documents with which,
uh,
Constantine supposedly made the donation
to the pope was Lorenzo Valla with a
philologist who went on examining
the language of the text.
And by examining that language,
found out that this, the,
the donation was not reading the document
had not possibly have been written in
the fourth century because the board,
the traces of 11th century,
uh,
Latin.
And so he went home and specifying that
that the region had been a forgery and
the forger had been
committed in, in a, in a,
in a convent in the south of France
with extraordinary linguistic position.
What is the,
why is this important to Dante?
Dante makes this issue of
the donation of Constantine,
the confusion of olders,
the spiritual and the secular,
which Simoni embodies Simoni
crystallizes the real problem of the,
the crisis of his own time.
So, so huge. I repeat that.
It's cold as the second scene of Adam
[inaudible] political texts called
Monarchia,
which is really an
argument in favor of the,
uh, the separation between these two
orders. The church and the state,
uh, had to be neatly divided
both to protect the state
from the intrusions of the
church and to protect the church from
the likely intrusions of the state.
So it's really an argument that
goes into, into two directions, uh,
so much then for to 19.
The last thing I have to save it as I
began talking about the rhetoric of the
profits and said the
profits really, um, uh,
use apostrophe ish apostrophes,
which are forms of lament are Simon.
You can see it's a kind of morning.
Uh, it's the language of, uh, of,
of, of, of grief frank primarily.
But there is also from a
linguistic point of view,
something else about unopposed
because an apostrophe,
it's has an indeterminacy of its own.
It's not really language.
He says nothing. It's,
it's a scream. But it's a,
the sense of we need to break the silence.
In other words,
you are using an apostrophe or emit
a cry because you cannot be quiet.
And that's really exactly what makes
this aspect of prophetic language so
crucial. It's between silence.
One is overcome by what?
One. The, the enormity of what one
sees and the refusal to acquiesce. So,
uh, and, and I should leave you are
constantly, that's another apostrophe.
There was also the whole
Cantu is punctuated by this
rhetorical form that wants
to break the silence and, and,
and cannot quite find the words.
That's what I call the indeterminacy
of the rhetorical artifice. Um,
let me just go, ah, I know that
I said that. We'll read 21.
Maybe I can talk about it.
I have to say very little about comedy.
Dante uses the language of comedy.
And what I had, I had with time,
I would talk about how Dante out
of the way, 21, two, is he an hour,
my comedy,
the language,
the humble style at this as if he
wants to free himself from the shackle,
the complications of using their lofty
language or taking on this extraordinary
position of being, being the profit of
his own times. So he goes on to their,
my comedy,
but it's common is also linked to a
peculiar experiencing it that he tells in
Canto 21,
the fear of falling,
the devils are after him.
And that was the, the, the,
of course he calls them a wealth and he
believes in other way of thinking about
them was the war between, he says whites
and blacks, Bianche and airy. That's,
that's the way that would distinguish
themselves. So this demons are,
his enemies are the
blacks, the, the, the, uh,
the Gibbons who are
trying to throw him down.
And the point is that comedy is always
attached to all is flagged with the idea
of the fall. Laughter.
This is where it begins.
At the moment when someone falls,
someone slips and,
and so we could really talk about that.
Had a little bit more but not much more.
Had a chance to,
if we had a little bit more time,
but I'm anxious to get into
26 and before we get to 26,
there is a passage in Canto
25 that I have to read.
Dante's been going through the Rome of
the thieves can took 24 and 25 and he is
overwhelmed by the metamorphosis,
the form of punishment of these thieves,
uh,
that goal and changing,
um,
form that become snakes that are
human beings bitten by snakes.
They become snakes that turned into
ashes and the recomposed themselves in an
endless cycle.
This is the punishment.
And Dante goes on writing as a poet,
breaking the flow of the narrative
of what is happening to him.
And this is what he says
he is. This is some 10, 25,
25 lines 90.
And following his, he describes the, uh,
actual reading from blinds
eight and following.
It's the lizard under the great scorge
of the dog days passing from hedge to
hedge seems lightening
if it crossed the way.
So appeared meeting for the
balance of the other two. A small,
fiery serpent,
livid and black has a peppercorn and
that part by which we were when we first
receive a nourishment,
it transfixed in one of them then fell
down before him stretched out the ones
that's fixed it,
but said nothing only stood still in
your mind as if sleep per fever had come
upon him. He kept looking at
the serpent and it at him.
The only one from the wound,
the other from the mouth smoked violently
and the smoke meth and now he's down
talking as a poet.
He breaks the account that the chronicle
what he has seen the witnessing since
that's what he is.
He's the witness in all of
these experiences and there
and that's what he says.
Let looking now be silent with his tales
of Richard's Abellio and the CTOs and
let him wait to hear what now comes forth.
Let all of it is highlands about card,
the most angelic Tusa for if in his
lines he turns him into a serpent and her
into fountain.
I do not grudge it to him
for two natures face to face.
He never saw transmuted that both kinds.
We're ready to exchange their
substance. All right. On the face of it,
Dante saying that the kind of
metamorphosis is describing really is,
um, more horrifying than anything says
that [inaudible] the author of the
metamorphosis or who is all his guidance,
his mom metamorphosis by a belief in the,
in the bondage and the bond of,
of,
in the solidarity between humans,
human beings, and the natural world.
We can go on shifting forms
and there is a kind of Syrian,
a transformation happening in,
in, uh, in, in, in, uh, innovate.
And he also, he also says
that he's different from
Luca and other author of, uh,
in of matter of a scene.
So metamorphosis in his
story about the civil war.
But the point that I,
that I think is really crucial
here is that it's a different one.
Dante is repeating,
reenacting exactly the kind of aesthetic
temptation that we already witnessed in
Canto four of inferno in limbo where
Dante meets the poet and he's so taken,
so complacent about undoubtedly that
great imputation of being sitting,
sitting with, uh, can
you imagine Houma Virgil,
Horace Lucan of it.
Exactly the people that he
mentioned them retrospectively,
that scene of harmony that can't have
four seem to dramatize now completely,
completely vanquished. You know, here he
is, he's really saying, I am their rival.
I am even better. I'm seeing things
that they didn't even imagine.
So if you had the illusion of an
idealic relationship among poets, uh,
you are this abused at this point.
But it is a temptation
nonetheless because once again,
Dante's going down for, in, in, in, in,
in an expo and the descent, which is
at the center of spiritual humility.
And yet his voice seems to be
going up in an opposite direction.
One of Hubris,
the same kind of temptation that he had
in Canto for, and this is what happens.
Again,
the structure repeats itself in Canto
for Dan pay claims that he built up a
fellowship,
a great poets.
He comes into pental five and he has to
confront the responsibilities of writing
the responsibilities of being a writer.
And he encounters his own.
A reader of his own Dante merges into
Canto 26 and meets none other than
Julissa's their master rhetorician whose
experience and whose journey will lead
himself and his are
companions to a tragic end.
For Dante. This is an extraordinary
moment for a number of reasons.
Ulysses is a steri point of
reference for his own adventure.
Ah,
he would keep thinking of him in Canton
19 Oh Purgatorio El Canto 28 or paradise
when Dante is about to leave beyond
the whole, the physical universe.
He looks back to see
this as he has traveled.
And the only thing that he sees is really
that passage way where you listen as
violated or boundaries clearly what
kind of boundaries in my violating you
listen as a mode of being a
possibility of being for Dante himself.
And so we come into Canto 26 and I
would like to take as much time as we
possibly can without tiring you
all, uh, about, uh, this can't,
let me begin with,
as I sought to preamble,
tell you a general, a
general, a general point.
Every school child in antiquity and
in Dante's on time knew one thing,
that Ulysses was a famous Greek hero,
polio tropic as homer calls him the main
of many terms, the many who knew it. All,
the men who had been seasoned
in order experiences.
They know that he had
done to the war of Troy,
that he was the one to suggest that the
building of the Trojan horse and the
stealing of the palladium, as you
know, the simulacrum of Minerva wisdom,
the figure of that,
the image of wisdom.
And then it took him that he was
involved in the bath or about inheriting
Achilles arbs with Ajax.
And then we,
everybody knew that it took him
10 years to return to Ithaca.
Right? This is a story of the Odyssey. He
turns, he goes to, we do not only that,
the, the, the nostrils as the
Greeks call, call it the return,
the journey of return.
He becomes the hero of nostalgia there
going back to a place that he has.
Everybody knew this in, uh, in Dante,
in antiquity, in Dante's times,
in antiquity.
They knew it very well because then
the story of Unisys had become a nun.
The as philosophical allegory
of the faith of the soul.
The idea of Ulysses who goes
from Ithaca to Troy and then go,
goes back for 10 years
after the war of 10 years,
another 10 years of vicissitudes,
cleansing himself in order to reach,
to go back to, uh, and, and, and,
and testing himself to go
back to his hometown, um,
was really the story of the soul.
That's what this whole does.
It's incarnates itself stroll
fee and the pissed of it.
It goes through the soul,
goes through the planets and gets
tainted by the attributes of the,
of the plan. At some of us are
lunatics, others are mercurial,
others are Saturnine, you
know, that's from the planets.
But then by cleansing ourselves, there's
salt and go back to its place of origin.
That's the circle of the return.
That's,
that's the way the Alexandra neoplatonists
understood the allegory of the
Odyssey.
So this is clear.
Dante violates this rule.
That's what you have in Canto
26 Dante begins with Ulysses,
his return to Ithaca and starts his
journeys of exploration all over again.
The idea of the eternal return,
the idea of a closure that
he has come back home is not,
not part of Dante's
imagination or sensibility.
He is [inaudible] the poet who is truly
restless and always placing himself and
his heroes on some kind of quest.
I want a method on a roads,
on an address, whatever, whatever the the,
the idea is the philosophers were always
on the road is in thinking about some,
some, some way of reaching wisdom,
reaching truth. That's where he puts them.
And that's what happens with the
story of, uh, of, of Ulysses. Ulysses,
uh,
starts all over again and goes and to
die is involved in a journey that is
absolutely the gratuitous,
a journey for wisdom,
for wisdom into the unpeopled world
who got to see this in the moment and,
and dies. That's, that's, that's
it from one point of view.
And I want you to be careful as you
read the Kantar because you will see,
you'll notice one thing,
the first thing you will notice is it's
not Dante who conducts the interview
with Ulysses. No, it is virtual.
The Port of Latin antiquity and supposedly
they speak may be Greek or some form
of, uh, clearly Greek.
Um, uh, it is Virgil,
the poet of the Aeneid who thinks of
himself as the fitting interlocutor of the
great Greek hero,
not Dantes,
Dantes excluded Dante just
watches and witnesses this.
But there is more to this idea of
stylistic, the core because one can say,
well,
Virgil,
this is in fact that as tragic
as a text get ever get supply,
this is not a comical text. This
is Virgil, the author of a tragedy.
That's where Dante calls
and the tragic style,
the sublime style and Julisa speeds in
the most in the loftiest way possible.
But it's not just a question
of stylistic decorum at stake.
There is something else you
listen disguises himself
as an ears as and tells the
story of his life as if he were an ESBL.
Now let me just tell you one little
thing and then we get into the Canto. Ah,
this is part of a story in many ways.
If you ask readers of Virgil and homer,
they probably will tell you, well
virtual, yeah, good port. But you know,
let's face it,
the first six books are just the,
all this say and the second books I just,
the yearly that he sort of gives her a
raise, you may have and so on. Not at all.
Not at all. And the difference
between the two heroes is this.
Ulysses is a place to go back to.
He goes Mythica to Troy back to Ithaca
and he has has no place to go to.
His is the open question.
The open the,
the road on open ended road
and open a red and the journey.
And this is the way you listen is,
will think of himself the further the
last thing and then the really we'll get
into the cancer.
The last thing I'll say is that
extraordinary ambiguity.
I want to point out the extraordinary
to be ambiguity with which Dante
represents Julissa's.
But the ambiguity of Unisys is part of
the story of Ulysses from the start.
The variant from the very beginning.
Ulysses is a philosopher
and he's a rhetorician.
He's someone who can
manipulate or knowledgeable
his own ends. And this, this,
this, this ambiguity that in
many ways, Dante is a fines.
Very alluring. Okay. Let's,
let me start with the Canto.
The Canto start starts
with, uh, uh, another,
uh, very topical relation. Uh,
very topical allusion. Dante is, uh,
joined their attention to a specific
place to the city of Florence.
It is as if he wants to a more himself
angle himself to something that's
concrete as his immediate
time, immediate place, uh,
his own native place. And, and, and, and
it's an apostrophe to Florence, rejoice,
Florence,
since that was so great.
Okay,
let me just stop here.
Moment. Pay Attention.
As you read the Canto,
pay attention to one,
a stylistic elements,
the antithetical,
the empathetical our use of great or uh,
tall and small at the same time.
Uh, rhetorically sometimes,
uh, all women with the
idea that uh, uh, of,
of making us ask and one that,
what is the relationship between within
that which claims to be so large and so
big and that which claims to be so small.
You list is obviously thinks of themselves
in terms of loftiness and Dante.
Now rhetorically starts with Florence in
south. So great. That's how tight it is.
Obvious that overland and see the Beatles,
they wings and through hell
they name it spread abroad.
The whole point is that he has seen some
Florentine thieves are named even among
the thieves are found five such
citizens of dine. That's shame for them.
Comes and once again,
the prophetic voice of Dante peers here
and that they will see that this is,
is fairly important in
the narrative we set out.
Second paragraph end on the stairs which
they're projecting rocks had made for
descent before.
My leader mounted again in drew me up
and following the lonely way among the
rocks and splinters of the ridge.
The food made new speed without the hand.
I grieved then
and grief now are new.
Then when he was a pilgrim watching
and witnessing the stories,
this is going to tell her and now
as a writer they said double focus.
That Dante's using the focus of the
pilgrim and the focus of the narrator I
grieved in and agree with.
Now our new,
when I turned my mind to what I
saw and more than I'm warrant,
I curb my powers and this is going to
be at least the attempt of Dante to curb
his powers as he witnesses the story
of immoderate hunger for knowledge of a
flight of the mind. That's what we
have here. The flight of the mind,
which is like the flight of battles,
which is like the flight of Icarus
that seems to know no boundaries.
Ulysses is he who transgresses all
boundaries but doesn't Dante also
transgressed boundaries? He
won't say, so here he wants,
it seems that he takes you listen as an
exemplary figure that would lead him to
want to curb his powers.
Let's continue, uh, uh, uh,
less, uh, less they run where
virtual does not guide them,
uh, in the languages that of
a horses. Of course horses,
the horses of the soul and virtue is
the ability to hold that black and the
white horse on the chariot,
uh, to hold them together.
And so that's the illusion with the t
that Dante is using and your platonic
language so that it favoring star or
something better have granted me such a
boon.
I mean not drudge it to myself.
And now the first description of
the landscape as some are landscape,
as many as the fireflies,
which the peasant resting on the hill in
the season when the heat at lights the
world least hides his face from us.
What an extraordinary emerge
at preferences to talk
about the sun is the night
when the sun is hiding.
And you'll see the
implications of this metaphor.
I hope we're in a moment seize along
the valley below in the fields.
Perhaps where the, he gathers the
grapes and entails with so many frames.
The eighth,
which was all gleaming is a perceived
as soon as I came where the bottom was
insight and this he,
that I was avenged but the bearish,
so the chariot of Elijah,
his departure when the host rear the
roads to heaven who could not follow it
with his eyes, so his to see
anything but the flame alone,
like a little cloud mounting up.
So each flay moves along the gullet of
the ditch for none shows the theft and
everyone steals away, uh, center. Uh,
Dante's not comparing himself to Elijah,
he's comparing to someone
who watches Elijah, Elijah,
who is also engaged in a
flight to fight to the soul.
Right, exactly. Like Ulysses
who is going to be represented.
It's the antithesis to your listeners,
but Dante is not that likely larger and
he would like us to believe that he's
not really like Ulysses.
He is like Ellie sales,
the one who inherits the mantle of
prophecy from Elijah and the one who,
who witnesses watchers. It's,
it's, it's, it's his way of,
of trying to avoid the extreme
of the profit. And now,
as it turns out, the iteration, this is,
this is the way they lay out here is
between Ulysses and, uh, and Elijah.
And so I was standing on the
bridge and then he goes on.
He's told them within the flames
are the spirits. She's a folk frame.
And there are two souls die,
uh,
erases and Diomede pay attention
until this little detail,
except in the case of the,
uh, the, the suicides,
Dante or reeses pairs of sinners.
Here's Diomede who doesn't
talk. And he sees also, uh,
he sees, uh, Ulysses.
And I suppose that the reason is that
Dante really wants us to know about the
social quality of a moral
violation that are moral violation.
All his implies, uh, somebody
else. It's not quite ever,
except for the suicide,
which has a peculiar form because you
have witness homicide and victim mode in
one. But in, in, uh, in, in the other
centers, you always have a sense of,
of, uh, uh, uh, a witness,
somebody else who has been touched
or an accomplice of, uh, uh, of,
of, of the center. Uh, so
within, we know that he answered,
who are these people I really wish
to us the who is that fire hose,
which comes so crew and at the top that
seems to rise from the buyer with a t
Oakleys.
What's led with this broader,
the stories that abide by the
two brothers were enemies,
ATO please and Polynese.
Thebes what are they
have an introduction of?
This is all about Greek mythology,
uh,
in Greek mythology with brothers
city over the story of Thebes,
which Dante knows through stages,
uh, the idea of the depots of course,
and Jocasta and the tragic city, uh, the,
the Thebes becomes, uh, the, uh,
the term becomes a
metaphor. The, the, the,
the basic metaphor of, uh, of the,
some of the tragic city app because in
effect presents also one of the reasons
that for dentist crucial,
it presents birth EEOC lists and Polynese,
um,
childs,
the children of either pose
and Jokasta is tragic events.
This is something that distinguishes
radically the Greek idea is Dante
understands it.
Uh,
the Greek idea of cities
and birth from say,
Virgil's idea of birth. You know,
something to be celebrated all the time.
None of Virgil is always the one
who celebrates the birth of a,
a senior's polio, et cetera.
Now we know who these are.
He answered me within there are tormented
within their tormented.
You listen,
that you made and that's together they
go on the vengeance as under wrath
cetera. If they're able to speak
within this lights. I said,
I earnestly pray the
master and pray again.
My prayer Availa thousand fold that
not forbid me to stay to the horn.
Flame comes near though ceased
how bent on it with desire.
And he said that prayer deserves
much praise for consent to it,
but to restrain that Kong
first little earlier,
he wants to curb his powers.
No,
Virgil asks him to restrain his time,
leave it to me to speak for,
have understood with a wishes for perhaps
since they were agreed that was the
same I speech. So we have really a
sense of the hierarchy of styles,
Virgil and your listeners.
And then in cancer 27,
it's going to be redone. The
MONTEFELTRO and Dante, uh,
or you are to who are to within one fire.
If I deserve what I lived,
if I deserve to you much
or little once again,
the oscillation between high and low,
much or little when in the world I
wrote the lofty lines, do not move on,
but let the one of you tell what
are being lost. He went to die.
The Greater Horn of the ancient
flame began to a murmur.
Justice if would've beaten
by the wind and weaving.
The point to and fro is it's
where the tongue of the spoke.
If Frank Fourth of voice and said when
I parted from Cersei who helped me more
than a year,
the guy atia before an ears so named it.
So you said clearly you list tells
his story through the myth of an ears
claiming priority of raininess but
also the knowledge in one thing.
It's an incredibly,
I find it a very moving line that uh,
any his names, places in
memory of his nurse. You know,
your names,
the city of gate.
He's a founder of cities
and names the CTO gator,
not fondness for her son,
no duty twin aged father,
not the love I owed Penelope.
Look at this,
what we call heavily ethical language.
You listen speaks in terms
of what his duties are,
fondness or sun,
the duty to alleged father liberties,
the love I owed Penelope,
which should have gladden
her could conquer within me
the passion I had to gain
experience of the world and the
vices and worth event. This is,
seems to be an ethical quest and nothing
can stand in the way of this virtuous
action.
You,
you as thinks of himself as a
virtuous Cuesta after visors.
Understanding and gaining experience of,
uh,
of vices and, uh, and, and,
and virtual and the worth of men.
And they put forth on the open
deep with that one ship, uh,
the one shore and the other I
saw as far as Spain and Morocco,
Sardinia and he's a man of,
you mentioned places all the time.
This narrative,
he always mentions places,
cities, Morocco, uh,
Seville sailed on the other
side of the Mediterranean. Um,
it is as if he is a man who
lives in space. He left,
his father, loves his son. That would
be a temporal description of him,
but he lives in space because it is,
if he never really knew
his own place in the world,
he's always looking for
something he doesn't even,
he doesn't know where he, he,
he, he belonged and, and I come,
my companions were old and slow when we
came to narrow out with per Hercules set
up his landmarks so that men should
not pass beyond on my right hand.
I left Seville on the other already left
Celta and now the speech he makes to
his own companions and look
at the rhetorical that a
torical wisdom with which
he moves, he addresses them as
brothers, which is the biggest cup.
Tatsuya benevolence. We are all
together. There is no hierarchy here.
I'm not your leader. I'm not
yo king or brothers. I said,
who threw 100,000 pedals?
Look at the hyperboles. Oh,
if you want to seduce people to
come companions to come with you,
you have to tell them that they
are mighty actions and he does.
And then magnify all the possible
dangers or hundred thousand pedals have
reached the west.
North definitely plays the
west vague and yet lofty, uh,
to this. So brief vigil of
the census. So the modesty,
the oscillation between
hyperbole and, and, and, uh,
the light totay as it were, the, the, the,
the recoiling into the sense
of orderliness and small
that remains to us choose
not to deny experience,
which I find an extraordinary word,
experience. And they probably will,
uh, uh, stop here with this experience,
as you know, is a word made only
of prepositions, uh, expert either.
It's a journey. It's going,
uh, through, uh, bear,
no experience.
It's understood is a journey.
It is as if knowledge,
that's what the etymology of the word is.
It's a going through,
uh,
it is knowledge literally is compared
to a displacement through a traveling,
uh, through, through a, Eh, uh,
Khattab assists even in this case,
which is the,
the,
the term to indicate the descent into
the beyond in the sands tracks of the
peopled, world tech thought of
the seed from which you spraying.
If you want to know the end of things,
you have to know the beginnings.
You have to know the seed,
Huh? Uh, this is the, the,
this is Julissa's perception.
Uh, and because we have a new
Boosie than you do know that your,
there's a kind of natural determination
in his own, uh, his own mind,
uh,
that he will reach in the noble end.
You were not born to leave as brutes,
but to follow virtual and knowledge
as extraordinary, extraordinary line,
uh, he promises that human
beings will leave behind.
What did the illusion may be through a
metamorphosis of Cersei that I changed
the companions into
pigs, right? The Koreans,
the hogs of Picuris into
the voluptuary experiences.
And he promises to re store in
them not only the human image,
but to bring them to a virtual knowledge.
And it's an extraordinary promise.
It's a very difficult promise.
It's almost an impossible promise.
It may even not be a correct promise
because he's making a promise that virtue
is knowledge.
I lead you to virtual knowledge
and they may not be the same thing.
I may have knowledge, but it does
mean that I have the virtue of that,
that I claim to have knowledge about.
And My, my, my, it can be anything.
Anything at all. I can know
what prudence is. It doesn't,
that doesn't really make me pull
it. That's, so let's stop here.
I'd want to stop here and I'm want to
see if there's some questions and then
resume next time with, uh, the camp. Yes,
USC is because people aren't
going to any definite place.
Is that what you said is like USC?
It's because people don't have
the question is uh,
I mentioned a,
actually Ulysses mentions knowing that
he speaks to Virgil mentions any years
and uh, uh, so that's the ad.
That's a y n e s and Julissa's.
Vaguely. That's true. Uh,
they clearly were fighting the
same battle and Troy verge,
a Ulysses must know that engineers had
lost his hometown and he took his son.
I like your recess. He took
his father on a, on, on his,
his back.
Literally they is immigrant and his son
and the lost his wife Crozer and goals
looking for a place without really
knowing, but it plays his, for him.
You leases knows what he wants to go.
He has a certain idea of its destination,
which is Ithaca.
He gets a lot of temptations along the
way. No C Cup. And what a temptation. Ah,
sir,
sir.
And other great temptation he manages to
move beyond those two conversations in
order to go back to Ithaca.
That's the great difference from,
from the Roman myth of the immigrant.
But in this version, aren't they still
really different because you, let's see.
I mean, he, his quest doesn't have any
direction at all. It's just experience.
Um, I'm unused. It's quest. He
doesn't know where he's going,
but there's still an overall
plan so that there is a definite
exactly, absolutely. So there is
a difference between them are,
becomes that that nes was
stop at one point. Uh,
he has temptations to stop in Sicily.
Oh, you remember their, that they're,
they're famous games.
Uh,
the games ritual games in memory of
his father who had died, the death,
that hallows, that ground. Then
the death of, of, of, of, of, of,
of, of unkindness that women
burn the ships just as weeks.
This is tube to, this is utopia. I don't,
we don't want to go around and do this
epic adventure. Let's stop here. He wants,
he's always a misunderstanding.
Oracle's, he doesn't know where to go.
He's always looking backwards,
but looking forward at the same time.
But at one point he stops he and the,
and that's part of, if you wish, the,
the realism of, of any as he
stops at one point, they cannot,
we will not go any,
any further.
Ulysses go spec home and then
he starts all over again.
But that's Danfoss reading of Ulysses.
Okay.
So he's really reading him as very much
like as if he would have a variant of a,
of Dante by the way.
Uh, yes, it's impossible.
I to be is to represent the dichotomy
between Dante, the poet and Dante,
the narrator as well,
because no one has a definite places
looking back at that place where he was
going. And the other is taking a journey
of experience in unsure where he's gone.
Uh,
the question is very interesting and it's,
is it possible to think of a nes and
your listeners is a two functions?
Is it were of Dante, the pilgrim
and the poet? Uh, yes and no.
Um, it's a very interesting
question. Um, but I, I would know,
um, I, I really hesitate to
agree with you for one reason.
Uh, because, uh, writing for Dante
is a prolongation of,
of the search than
politically can not stop.
It's not that, you know, he on the face
of it, he has seen the beatific vision,
right?
That's new to the story.
The story of a man who goes from
the wilderness goes to hell,
purgatory paradise and here's a beatific
vision and now he starts telling us
about it. A fighting against
forgetfulness. You know, here's a lot of,
as a writer,
he is a lot of temptations and yet
the writing itself is fraught with,
with uh, dangers, temptations.
It's a different sort of journey,
but it's the journey of writing and
therefore there's no clear cut distinction
between the two. I, in fact,
I just read in Canto 25, uh,
the little scene when he
challenges Luca and dove in,
which it really is, let the past yield
to the present. You know, that's, that's,
that's really the kind of
claim that they can make. Uh,
let them be quiet cause I know what
is happening and the stories that is a
writer,
he is a lapsing his falling into a number
of them as if it were to peel them.
You can expect that from a pilgrim
to being fat, being fascinated by,
uh, by Francesca. I'm having all this, uh,
in the divisions,
Dante is a deeply divided man.
He has to calm them and at the same
time has to sympathize as, as a,
even as a pilgrim.
So that's really the,
that's that's the only little
detail would I would, uh, uh,
I would not agree with you, but
maybe you have right? I Dunno.
Oh yes. Can you speak about
the fact that nothing changes?
The ending is stories and had some
drowned at sea that have intertwined the,
again,
he returned. Uh, the question is,
can I speak about how Dante changes
the ending of your list? A story.
And the answer is this,
uh,
Dante makes you listen
this go back to Ithaca,
but then he breaks the
circle of this close circle.
Let's call it the circle of the epic. Let
me talk formally about it. You know, the,
the idea is that you are what,
what are some traits of the epic,
the epics deal with foundations of
cities and destruction of cities all the
time, no matter what the city
may be. So he has destroyed,
they said it goes back to uh, to
his own city to cleanse it. That's,
which is Homer's way
of saying, I think, uh,
you Greeks were so, so great when
you were out in the world that Troy,
let us see how that heroic
ethos is going to help you,
that you are back home where the probably
you are going to need more courage and
more determination,
as much courage,
at least as much determination
as you did have, uh, in,
in that great celebration of the newly
found Greek unity, uh, in, in Asia,
minor in, in, in Troy. So that's that.
Now Dante takes that ntss no,
there's no closure here because he
rejects the idea of Dante to the epic.
He replaces the epic with a novel.
This becomes a kind of novelistic story.
Where is where we're in a experience
is being arrived at as one goes.
You see what I'm saying? In the
epic, you have a kind of, uh,
indeed things return to the poets of,
uh,
of departure. Uh, that's,
so that's the difference.
It's a difference between two radically
different ways of understanding
experience and the self down to
put himself on the open road.
But you listen will remain
that constant reminder to him.
He's the phantasm.
He can never quite exercise.
It will return to him.
I said,
when the siren appears and temps,
the pilgrim says,
your look I made,
I gave happiness two uteruses.
Why don't you stay with me?
And the implication is, first
of all, she's lying. Uh,
because this is,
you know,
the story of your is pouring the wax
in these years is a nice and omitted,
but it's a way,
a temptation to Dante to feel that
he too is an epic hero like Ulysses.
Okay. Did I answer other questions?
We'll come back to this
cancer, which is a truly, um,
plays a crucial role in
Dante's imagination and in the,
in the divine communists, in the
unfolding of the divine comedy. So, uh,
read carefully. Then we'll go on
to the other cantors. Thank you.